this morning we're learning about a
surprising comeback for a controversial
food ingredient the seasoning known as
MSG it used to be widespread but fell
out of favor over perceived health
concerns now research tells us many of
those concerns are unfounded and the
fears may be rooted in xenophobia rather
than science CBS correspondent Michael
George spoke with Two Chefs who cook
with MSG about what they say are
misconceptions and they also have some
clever ways that it's being used today
at this Arlington Virginia takeout
restaurant lucky Danger
Chef Tim Ma's secret ingredient isn't
really a secret MSG is very little
it's a seasoning with a controversial
history many Americans grew up hearing
it's unhealthy or even dangerous to
consume but now some like ma are
challenging that idea I will say I think
every dish has it in there we actually
sit it here on the walk station because
it is the last component of every dish
that goes out dishes like Kung Pao
chicken and dumplings ma was born into a
family of immigrants with a legacy of
Chinese cuisine his parents started
Bamboo Garden in Arkansas and his
uncle's restaurant Palmas China Kitchen
was featured in a Smithsonian exhibit on
Chinese food in America being a cook or
being a chef was very easy for them to
fall into and a way for them to make a
living but Ma's family never used MSG no
MSG was a badge of honor in a Chinese
restaurant there was a lot of stigma
like anti-asian sentiment around that
and the MSG just like fell into that
chef and author J Kenji Lopez alt says
the safety of MSG or monosodium
glutamate first came into question in
1968 when a doctor wrote a letter to the
New England Journal of Medicine titled
Chinese restaurant syndrome this wasn't
a published study there was a letter
written to the journal by a doctor
saying hey I've noticed when I go to
Chinese restaurants and eat MSG rich
foods I get these certain symptoms after
others reported similar symptoms an MSG
backlash began some critics targeted
Chinese restaurant owners at a time when
anti-asian sentiment was high the
Chicago Tribune even ran this headline
the whole idea has some racist
undertones as well because Chinese
restaurants had a reputation for being
sort of low quality food or dirtier food
some people still claim to experience
symptoms such as headaches or drowsiness
after eating foods containing MSG but
recent scientific research shows that
when consumed in moderation MSG is
harmless
in culinary practice MSG is a flavor
booster we all know the taste salty
bitter sweet and sour MSG triggers the
fifth taste Umami a sort of savoriness
or meatiness while MSG is often
associated with Asian Cuisine it's long
been an ingredient in American foods
from Campbell's soups and Heinz Ketchup
to KFC and Chick-fil-A you never hear
somebody say I have Doritos syndrome or
KFC syndrome if you don't hear about it
as like a specific term the way Chinese
restaurant syndrome is the ingredient is
now seeing a comeback even in some
unusual ways all right so this first
one's just going to be a regular Lopez
all showed us how MSG can be used in
cocktails he set up this taste test
oh this is different I'm gonna guess
that this is the one with MSG in it
correct I get that savory flavor you
were talking about back at lucky danger
Ma's slogan is American Chinese by a
Chinese American this is really taking
the dishes that have been Americanized
like Kung Pao chicken General Tso's and
just updating it some people would say
it might just be easier for you to avoid
the whole thing and not use MSG but then
the food won't be as good it's a very
necessary ingredient for us
so look MSG may not be for everyone and
that's okay but now some of the stigmas
about MSG are Vanishing and people are
starting to realize hey this is pretty
good and it works in scrambled eggs even
apple pie what apple pie you think
Savory not sweet it tends to be better
in Savory food but folks some folks are
sensitive to it absolutely and I think
the big takeaway here is if you are
sensitive to it sure steer clear it's
good to think of it like Dairy some
people are lactose intolerant and they
should avoid Dairy but that doesn't mean
that Dairy is dangerous or unsafe it's
the same with MSG yeah isn't it just
particular to the person eating right
just like you said gluten or other
ingredients that you might be sensitive
to absolutely there are sensitivities
out there and and just kind of trust
your own system and just say hey this
doesn't really sit well with me olive
oil well if it's in Chick-fil-A it's
good enough for me and Doritos too
absolutely
appreciate